mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
five and three over some number
multiplied by another number and one
half
is equal to nineteen
solve for the two numbers
here's an equivalent way of stating the
problem
suppose the two numbers are equal to m
and n
we can rewrite the multiplication in the
following fashion
we want 3 over m to be a fraction in
lowest terms
and we want n to be a whole number
that's greater than or equal to 1.
so the challenge is to solve for the
values of m and n
i thank ramesh for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will present one solution that uses
algebra and another solution that uses
inequalities
let's get started with algebra
let's start with this form of the
problem
we will use a trick of rewriting each
term in this product
let's rewrite the first term in this
product
5 is equal to 5 m over m
thus the first term can be rewritten as
5 m plus three all over m
now let's rewrite the second term in
this product
n is equal to two n over two
which means the second term in the
product is equal to two n plus one all
over two
since we are multiplying these fractions
the denominator becomes two multiplied
by m
we can then multiply both sides by two
multiplied by m
from here we will use a bit of number
theory
since n is a whole number that's greater
than or equal to 1
2 n plus 1 is an odd number
that means 5 m plus 3 must be an even
number and it must have a factor of 2.
furthermore
3 over m is a fraction in lowest terms
so m cannot be a multiple of three
this means that m does not divide five m
plus three
then because three is a prime number m
and five m plus three are relatively
prime
this means there are two possible cases
for five m plus three
one case is that five m plus three could
be equal to two
but in that case m would be equal to
negative one-fifth
and this is a problem because we know
that three over m is a fraction in
lowest terms so m has to be a whole
number that's greater than or equal to
two
so we can exclude this possibility
so the other possibility is that 5m plus
3 is equal to 2 multiplied by 19.
this is equal to 38 which means that m
is equal to 7
if m is equal to seven we can substitute
in
and since five m plus three is equal to
thirty-eight we can see that two n plus
one must be equal to seven
this means that n is equal to 3.
so we have one possibility let's go
ahead and check it
we substitute in the values for m and n
and this in fact is a solution to the
equation
5 and three over seven
multiplied by three and a half is equal
to nineteen
so this is one way to solve the problem
but i wanna go over another way that
uses inequalities i actually figured
this out after i went through the
algebra
but i think it's an easier way or at
least a quicker way to solve the problem
so i wanted to present it
let's focus on the term 5 and 3 over m
notice that it's between 5 and 6.
also all of these numbers are positive
so if we take the reciprocal of each
term we will flip the inequality sign
we can then multiply each term by 19.
the upper bound is 19 over 5 which is
equal to 3.8
the lower bound is 19 over 6 which is
equal to 3 and 1 6.
this means 19 divided by 5 and 3 over m
must be
something that has a whole number part
that's equal to 3.
this means that n is equal to three so
we've immediately solved for the value
of n
from here we can substitute in
we then take nineteen divided by three
and one half
this is equal to nineteen divided by
seven halves which is equal to 38 over
seven which is equal to five and three
over seven
thus m is exactly equal to seven
and we've immediately solved the problem
using inequalities we get the solution
that m is equal to seven and n is equal
to three
incredible
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you